الى غزه الان من هناك ينضم الينا الدكتور
حسام الدجني الكاتب والمحلل السياسي دكتور
حسام مرحبا بك تقييمك لما حدث
يعني مساء الخير لك ولكافه المشاهدين اذا
اردنا ان ننظر الى ما حدث يجب ان نضع كافه
السيناريوهات وننتظر نتائج التحقيق حتى
نقول اين هو السيناريو الصحيح في تقديري
ان دوافع منفذ العمليه ربما السيناريو
الاول وهو ينسجم مع بيان القوات المسلحه
ان خطا ما حدث في المنطقه وتجاوز الجندي
الحدود عندما كان يلاحق بعض المهربين
وبذلك تم الاشتباك مع الجنود الاسرائيليين
وتم تحييده واستشهاد واستشهاده ومقابل
مقتل ثلاثه اسرائيليين السيناريو الثاني
هو دافع قومي اي عمليه بطوليه قام بها هذا
المجند في ظل
الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه المتكرره ولا يمكن
ان نفصل تداعيات اقتحام المسجد الاقصى عن
البعد القومي والبعد الوطني والبعد الديني
لكافه ابناء الامه العربيه والاسلاميه
وبذلك قد يكون احد الدوا هو ما يحصل في
غزه وما يحصل في القدس السيناريو الثالث
هو ربما يحاكي سيناريوهات سابقه حدثت مثل
هذه الاحداث اي الاستفزاز المتكرر الذي
يتعرض له الجنود المصريون حرس الحدود على
وجه التحديد في منطقه الحدود مع مصر
والبالغه ما يقارب 200 كيلو متر طول هذه
الحدود يتعرض الجندي المصري الى استفزازات
ربما اشهرها حادثه العلم عندما قام احد
الجنود المجندات الاسرائيليه بمسح العلم
المصري بحذائها ثم تم ممارسه غزيل امام
الجنود وامام العين احرص الحدود فقام
احدهم باطلاق النار وتم مقتل هذه المجنده
احتراما وكرامه للعالم المصري وتم اعتقال
هذا المجلد سمات الجندي المصري هي
الالتزام بقواعد قواعد التي يفرضها عليه
قيادته وبذلك من المبكر ان نقول ما هي
السيناريو الاكثر ترجيحا ولكن هنا تساؤل
مهم جدا ربما يعني نطرحه نحن كمراقبين هو
تناقض الروايه المصريه والاسرائيليه
في ظل الدول ان يفهم الكبير
وانما اختلاف تباين في الروايتين من جهه
الروايه المصريه تربط الموضوع
بعمليه تهريب للمخدرات حدثت ومن جهه ثانيه
الروايه الاسرائيليه
تستبعد هذه الفرضيه
وتتحدث عن ان العمليه عمليا استمرت لساعات
وادت الى مقتل الجنود هؤلاء وجرح احدهم
كيف تفهم هذا التباين في الروايتين حتى
الان
يعني هذا ياخذنا الى احتماليه ان بنيامين
نتنياهو واركان الحكومه الاسرائيليه تريد
ان توظف هذه العمليه في اطار كي وعي لكل
الذين ينادون ويضغطون على نتنياهو بان
يذهب الى مواجهه عسكريه اما بالجبهه
الشماليه مع حزب الله او ايران او بالجبهه
الجنوبيه مع قطاع غزه وبذلك يحاول ان يقول
للجميع ان اسرائيل في خطر او هناك
احتماليه اخرى انه يريد ان يذهب الى
مواجهه ويريد ان يقول للولايات المتحده ان
التهديد على دوله الاحتلال يتطلب موقف
امريكي ايجابي وقوي في مواجهه ايران وفي
كبح جماح الارهاب اينما كان مصدره وبذلك
يحاول ان يوظف هذه العمليه في هذا الاطار
في تقديره ان طبيعه العلاقات المصريه
الاسرائيليه الذي تقوم في ملفات التابعه
هذا هذا الراي تردد سابقا لماذا يستغل
نتنياهو هذه الحادثه عند الحدود المصريه
بالنظر الى
العلاقه بين مصر واسرائيل ولا يستغل حوادث
اخرى ربما في هذا المجال تحدث بشكل اكبر
عند الحدود الشماليه او عند الحدود مع غزه
لماذا عند الحدود المصريه والان
لا هو الحدود مع غزه والحدود الشماليه هي
جبهات ملتهبه حتى وان كان هناك تهدئه لكن
الحدود الهادئه جدا هي الحدود المصريه
والحدود الاردنيه وبذلك في حال حدث اي حدث
مع الحدود الاردنيه او الحدود المصريه
ياتي هنا التوظيف ومحاوله الضغط على
المجتمع الدولي لان يكون هناك دعم
لاسرائيل واسناد عسكري لاسرائيل من اجل
تنفيذ مهامها في ردع ايران وفي ردح حماس
والجهاد الاسلامي وفي رجع حزب الله وبذلك
هذا ربما الاكثر ترجيحا في طبيعه توظيف
الاحتلال دون ان يكون هناك اتصالات بحكم
العلاقه مع مستوى التوافق على احتواء
الحدث تستطيع اسرائيل ان تحتوي الحدث من
اللحظه الاولى من خلال ان تتبنى الروايه
المصريه ويتم يعني الحدث بشكل اساسي
احتوائه بشكل اساسي لكن هذا التعارض او
هذا التباين في تقدير ان له ما بعده
بالنسبه لاسرائيل وربما مصر تدرك ذلك وهذا
ما يفسر محاوله مصر تفويت الفرصه عدم
الحديث الاعلام المصري بشكل مفصل عن هذه
العمليه وترك الامور الى البعد المهني
الموضوعي المتعلق بانتهاء نتائج التحقيقات
طيب كيف وجدت الحرص حرص رئيس الحكومه
الاسرائيلي على القول بان التعاون الامني
مع مصر قائم ان العلاقات لن تتاثر ماذا
وراء ما الرساله من وراء تكرار ذلك
يعني في تقدير لن تستغني اسرائيل عن الدول
المصري الدوري المصري مهم جدا في استقرار
المنطقه مصر دوله مركز مصر دوله رئيسيه في
اطار الملف الفلسطيني وعلى وجه التحديد
ملف قطاع غزه وبذلك لا يمكن
نتنياهو ان يقول غير ذلك مصر تربطها
علاقات في مع الولايات المتحده وتربطها
علاقات مع الاقليم وبذلك لا يمكن ان
تتجاوز الحدود اللياقه الدبلوماسيه
اسرائيل في خطابها اتجاه مصر هذا ما تحدث
به بنيامين نتنياهو لانه بالتاكيد هذه
العلاقات لا تفرق بها اسرائيل لانه في حال
كان هناك العداء وصل الى درجات عاليه
بالتاكيد هذا لا يخدم امن اسرائيل ولا
يخدم توجهات دوله الاحتلال في محاوله
تحييد قطاع غزه وجبه قطاع غزه في حال ذهبت
باتجاه مواجهه مع طهران او مواجهه مع حزب
الله في لبنان
اشكرك اذا حتى الان من غزه الدكتور حسام
الدجلي الكاتب والم حلل السياسي